I'm gonna be real with y'all.
Today did not go as planned.
We are all kinda just in a mood.
We have a lot going on with the house,
and I think the kids are starting to feed off of Logan.
And I stress they're picking on each other,
not listening, and just not motivated to do their school work.
Now, I get it.
I have off days, and it's only fair that they do, too.
We did poetry, our read aloud,
and our geography, and then I sent them to the room for some alone time.
After their quiet time, they did come back and get some math seeds done,
so I feel a little bit better about the day,
but overall, it just feels like a wash.
Normally, when we have bad moods or big emotions,
we go outside, but it is 104 degrees outside,
and that felt more like torture than anything.
So instead, we're all just gonna have some space,
give a little bit of Grace, and try again tomorrow.